What happened at Pompeii?
Explained like you are 5.
Step 1.
It is 79 AD.
Pompeii is a Roman city of 20,000 people.
Wealthy, busy, full of markets, bathhouses, and taverns, the city sits at the base of
a large mountain, Mount Vesuvius.
Nobody knows it is a volcano.
The Romans have no word for volcano.
No eruption has been recorded in living memory.
The mountain is simply there, beautiful, covered in vineyards, the soil around it, the richest
in the region.
Because of what is inside it, nobody knows that either.
Step 2.
In February of 79 AD, the ground starts shaking.
Wells dry up overnight.
Animals refuse to enter the city.
The Romans interpret these as bad omens.
They sacrifice animals to the gods.
They do not evacuate.
On the 24th of August 79 AD at 1 PM, Vesuvius explodes.
A column of ash and gas shoots 21 miles into the sky.
It is 100,000 times more powerful than the Hiroshima bomb.
The sky turns black at noon.
Ash begins falling like snow.
Step 3.
Most people try to wait it out indoors.
This is the wrong decision.
The ash builds on rooftops.
Buildings collapse under the weight.
Then the pyroclastic surge.
A wave of superheated gas and ash moving at 180 mph, 700 degrees.
It reaches Pompeii in four minutes.
Everyone still in the city dies instantly.
Not slowly.
Instantly.
So extreme it vaporizes flesh.
What remains?
Body-shaped voids in the hardened ash.
Step 4.
Pompeii is buried under 20 feet of volcanic material and forgotten.
For 1,700 years, rediscovered in 1748, excavations find the city exactly as it was left.
Bread still in the ovens.
Graffiti still on the walls.
The body voids filled with plaster reveal people in their final positions.
A dog.
A family huddled together.
A man covering his face.
The most complete snapshot of ancient Roman life ever found.
Preserved perfectly by the thing that destroyed it.
And that's just one story inside paladin.
It's like Duolingo, but for history lovers, download it now and become the most intelligent
person in the room.